- As we all know, I invited
my cousin Zack to join the
fantasy football league.
- Can't we just play with seven?
(knocking)
- Hey, is this the right spot?
Kyle, what's up man?
Hey, thanks for letting me join
the league this year.
- Yeah, trust me it wasn't my decision.
- Give him a chance.
Maybe he'll end being your best friend.
- Ryan was my best friend.
- Well Ryan left you for Europe.
- [Kyle] I'm having a
cool party this weekend,
you should roll through.
- Hey Justin, you're up
for the beer pong tournament.
- I can't play guys.
You know my regular partner is in Europe.
- I'll be your partner.
(Justin scoffs)
- Okay.
- Just don't get in the way, okay?
I don't want you messing
up my perfect record.
(liquid splash)
- You were saying?
(upbeat music)
- Wow.
- I wasn't sure about this guy,
but now things are slowly changing.
He likes me for me.
- I think you should go over there.
If don't, I will.
- Okay, you know what. I get it.
I'm gonna go talk to her.
I'm Justin and I don't normally do this.
- [Justin] One, two, three. Yeah.
(laughing)
(alarm signal)
- I feel like we're losing that ambition.
That drive, you know?
Like when I have kids
one day, I want to be,
say hey you could walk
on the moon one day.
You know, you could be
the next Michael Jackson
for all we know.
I don't know it's stupid.
- [Justin] No, it's not stupid.
- Justin man, I don't know
if I can hang out tonight.
I just had a really stressful
day at work and I --
- Hey, I got beer can
chicken going in the oven
and I got Fast 7 on
Blu-ray, but I understand
if you want me to go.
- This is exactly what I needed.
- Hello Justin.
- Ryan? But I thought you were in Europe.
- I'm back now dude.
I'm sorry, who's this?
- I'm Zack, I'm Justin's
new, uh, his new friend.
- Any mate of Justin's is
a mate of mine you know.
- I'm just going to take off.
- No, no. It's fine.
- [Ryan] Come on stay.
- Nice meeting you.
- You are my number one mate. Bruv.
- [Justin] Hey, this is Justin.
I can't pick up right now cause --
- [Ryan] He's hanging
out with his best friend
who just back from Europe.
- [Ryan] You think Justin
actually likes you?
How embarrassing. Ta ta.
- Yo. Why didn't you set the pick?
- It's really about the pick?
- You bailed on me.
- Were you getting my stamps from Europe?
- [Justin] It was cool. Looks
like you had a good time.
- [Ryan] It's not just a good
time, it's an important time.
This is when we pick, the
people that we stay with
or the people that we leave behind.
I want you to come with me to Europe.
- (speaking foreign language)
- Still so weird seeing a menu in English.
Justin? What's going on man?
You haven't touched your crepe.
- I'm sorry, but I gotta go.
- Justin.
(upbeat song)
- [Justin's Aunt] (foreign language)
- Zack!
- Auntie!
(laughing)